[Music]
so
let me maybe start by saying which part
of physics i'm talking about
specifically physics is a really large
discipline and has a lot of
sub areas i'm talking about the
foundations of physics
in particular in this discipline
we deal with those natural laws which
cannot be derived for we currently know
from any underlying laws so this is
currently the theory of general
relativity
um which was conceived by einstein about
100 years ago
and describes the behavior of space and
time and then we have what's called
the standard model of particle physics
that collects
25 particles that
we currently think are fundamental and
cannot be further divided
and this model also explains how this
how these particles
interact so what's going on
in the foundations of physics um in one
word
nothing there is a lot of talk about
crisis crisis crisis crisis crisis
um this has been going on for about 10
years something like this
um so so what are these people referring
to
well um we have not made progress in the
foundations of physics
for about 40 years and this problem is
becoming
more pressing year after year general
relativity as i already said
is more than 100 years old and
the theory pretty much has not changed
we use it today the same way that
einstein wrote it down and the
development of the standard model
was largely completed in the mid 1970s
and ever since then the foundations of
physics have remained
unchanged there have been a few
constants and a few details been added
here and there
for example general relativity has
a free constant that's called the
cosmological constant that was long
believed to be zero we now know that
it's not
so we put this constant back in
but the idea goes back already to
einstein um in the
standard model we have added some masses
for particles called the neutrino
we have also of course not discovered
all the particles already in the 1970s
there were lots of
discoveries missing at the time um
for example the heavier quarks had not
been discovered
in the 1970s and the higgs boson as many
of you
would probably have heard was only
experimentally confirmed
in 2012 however the theory for the higgs
boson goes back already to the 1960s
and also the theory for the neutrino
masses it's actually even older goes
back to the 1950s
so um the mathematical structure of
these theories
has remained the same but we know that
that's not it
so we can't just say well maybe that's
just the end of the story we have
discovered the foundations of nature and
that's it we know that these theories
have unsolved problems that require
solutions
the most pressing problem i think is
that the standard model does not want to
work together with
general relativity that's because um the
standard model is ultimately a theory
for particles with quantum properties
which means among other things that they
obey
heisenberg's uncertainty principle and
this just does not fit together with
general relativity which has these
particles as
sources because we know that they have
masses and masses generated
gravitational pull
but general relativity does not know
anything about the uncertainty principle
so mathematically combining the two just
produces
rubbish and we know that there has to be
some solution to that
and it's called a theory of quantum
gravity but we don't actually have
that theory we also have some
observational problems
that require solution for example what
is
dark matter we have a lot of
astrophysical observations that tell us
if
we look at the cosmos and we try to
describe what we see just by using the
matter that
is in the standard model and general
relativity then it doesn't work
it seems to be the case that there is
more matter in
galaxies or that the gravitational pull
is just
stronger so there are currently two
different ways of trying to explain
these observations that's either
that there is some kind of particle that
is not in the standard model which
generates
generates this additional gravitational
pull that's what's called dark matter
dark because uh we can't actually see it
we only notice its gravitational
attraction the other possibility is that
uh there's something about gravity that
we just don't
understand and this goes under the name
modified gravity
either way there's something about the
foundations
of physics that needs to change to
explain these observations and then
there are other questions like how did
the universe begin what's with the
measurement
process and quantum mechanics and so on
and so that they're good
reasons to think that um we have not
found what's ultimately the correct
description
of nature and yes these
are hard questions uh physics is a very
mature discipline
it's one of the oldest scientists that
there is and the
simple things have been done so you
expect some kind of slowdown for example
because it becomes
more and more difficult to make
experiments
that probe areas where we have not
already found out everything that there
was uh to
be found out this is why we see larger
and larger experiments larger and larger
collaborations
uh more and more expensive experiments
um of course
but the main reason for the slowdown is
not
this difficulty because we still make
these experiments
um and um we still see a lot of
theoretical
activity in these areas it's just that
it doesn't seem to be going anywhere
it's like people are running faster and
faster but they're running on a
treadmill not getting
anywhere so what's really the cause of
the problem
is bad methodology and group think
what's what's really um at the core of
the problem is that physicists and
foundations of physics
rely on beauty to discover the next
best fundamental law they
think that the foundations of physics
the way that we currently have them
as as with general relativity and the
standard model are just not
pretty enough these theories leave them
wanting for various reasons
for example in the standard model we
have three different types of
interactions
um there is the electromagnetic
interaction that
uh most of you will probably have heard
of um and then there
is the strong and the weak nuclear force
but these kind of sit next to each other
in a quite awkward way and it would be
much prettier if there were
ultimately all three aspects of one
large interaction that would be
described by a one symmetry group so
this is what is called
a grand unified theory and it's just
aesthetically much
more appealing and this is why a lot of
physicists think that this is how nature
should work so i have this little image
here
um which shows you a certain kind of
symmetry group which is called e8 uh you
can think of these little dots basically
as being
particles with a certain properties uh
charge um
color color charge spin and so on and
these lines as being the connections
between
um the particles so this is one of the
possible
um beautiful theories that physicists
are considering um in the foundations to
make the standard model
prettier the problem is they invent
these prettier theories
and then they go out and try to test
them usually by spending a lot of money
because
as i just said these experiments are not
cheap and then they are surprised if no
evidence is found to support
them it's even worse than that actually
because
they also don't get the message that
this is a procedure which clearly is
working
but they've been doing this since the
1980s and
they do not learn the lesson
part of the problem is that they are
largely unaware that this is what they
are doing
because these requirements of beauty
have become mathematical standards
um so a lot of physicists will actually
be really really offended if you tell
them
that they rely on beauty because they
don't know that that's what they're
doing
the science writer jim beggart suggests
to call this
a metaphysical commitment instead of
arguments from beauty
yes that's how you can think of it you
know i i prefer to talk about beauty
because it's
a somewhat more digestible word um i
also think that
um it's it's um ultimately where these
arguments come from
it's the reason why physicists would
want nature to be in this particular way
is because it would be more beautiful
but metaphysical assumptions is exactly
what it is these are assumptions about
nature
that themselves are not based on
evidence their beliefs basically
um so what's the consequence of this
well um there are lots of
failed predictions that have come out of
this belief that nature has to be
beautiful
in very specific mathematical ways i
will now
briefly go through some of those for
example the standard model contains a
number which is called the
theta parameter which is small and
physicists think that small numbers are
ugly so they don't like that
they've tried to make this theory
prettier um
in a certain specific way that doesn't
really matter for our purposes
and this prettier theory predicts a new
particle which was called the axion
this particle was proposed and ruled out
very quickly
after its proposal in the 1970s
but what then happened and this is
symptomatic what uh
to what would happen over and over again
physicists did not just abandon this
idea of the axiom
but instead they amended the theory
um so that they had a new axiom which
was more difficult to
observe and this was called the
invisible axiom
actually if you look at the literature
today um they've just dropped the term
axion and a lot of especially the
younger students don't even know that
um this axion that they're dealing with
today is not the original
axion there have been a lot of
experiments looking for these
axions and you see one in this
image in the corner so far
nobody has seen an axiom the trouble is
they're invisible so this
theory was deliberately designed so that
it
is difficult to test
another one of the failed predictions is
that as i briefly mentioned the standard
model
is not as symmetric as it could be i
have a little graph of the standard
model you know you have all these
particles that kind of they have some
structure but it's not
particularly great you know it could be
better you know
i can think of ways to make it better
other people have thought of smarter
ways to make it better
and these are the grand unified theories
um they're arguably pretty
um now the thing is that once you have a
theory
of that type it um predicts some new
interactions and those have generically
the consequence that protons are
unstable
they decay now you can look for this you
can look at protons for example water is
basically
made of protons so what you do to test
this
is you very closely monitor large
amounts of water
to see if there are any protons decaying
uh so far no one has seen a single
proton decay
this does not entirely rule out these
theories um it has ruled out some of
them
um but there are always ways that you
can fiddle with these
theories so that um the proton is a
little bit longer lived
so it is not affected by the
observations that we have
so far um then
many of you will probably remember that
the large hadron collider which you see
in this image
um we're supposed to see other things
besides the exposure there was a lot of
talk about
supersymmetric particles or maybe tiny
black holes additional dimensions
those were supposed to show up at the
large hadron collider
why did so many physicists think that
this
should be the case well it's that the
standard model is ugly
in a very specific way besides the theta
parameter it contains another number
that is small which is the mass
of the higgs boson or more precisely
it's the mass of the exposure divided by
something called the planck mass
that comes out to be very small and
physicists don't like that
so what you can do is you can make this
theory prettier
for example by adding supersymmetry to
it or additional dimensions
and because that theory is prettier
physicists thought
that well nature should go for it and
we should see these things that the
larch hadn't collided it turned out
to not work the only new particle that
was seen was
the higgs boson that was predicted in
the 1960s
and i have to emphasize that this was
not a prediction
um based on an argument from beauty it
was a prediction based
on inconsistency um without the higgs
boson the standard model is just
inconsistent it stops working at
energies that the lhc can reach
another failed prediction um is for a
specific type of particles that
are supposed to make up dark matter
these are the so-called weakly
interacting massive particles
um these have been sought for since the
mid 1980s
uh so far none have been seen each time
time and experiment comes back
empty-handed theorists go and here
it it happens again and make their
theories more complicated so that the
particles um
are more difficult to detect what you
see in this little
image in the corner is a dark matter
detector called xenon 1t
this is an upgrade from xenon 100 which
is an upgrade from xenon 10 which is an
upgrade of the original xenon experiment
in each upgrade the sensitivity of the
detectors was increased they still
haven't
seen the thing why did physicists
believe in that
well it's because the wimps are supposed
to explain a numerical coincidence that
has um gone down in the literature under
the name wimp
miracle um that's basically
um the coincidence that um
particles of a certain mass that is in
the range
of the large hadron collider would have
been produced in the early universe in
about the right amount to make
up for the observed effects of dark
matter
um so you know that that may just be
coincidence
but um theorist theoreticians
in uh the foundations believe that
there's something more here than
than just a mere coincidence because if
it was just coincidence that would be
ugly
um then in general relativity we have
also um
a constant um that is very small
emphasis think it's ugly that's the
previously mentioned cosmological
constant
um again you can try to make this theory
prettier
by um making it more complicated and
trying to do without this constant um
usually the way that you do this
is by converting the constant into some
kind of dynamical field
that changes during the evolution of the
universe
um you can look for these kind of fields
um
at least for some of them and to the
extent that it has been possible to look
for them
and they were not found
so um i think this this gives you some
idea of
um why i think it's not a good idea to
um rely on arguments from beauty it just
has um
worked very badly for physicists in the
last 40 years
so they haven't given up on it so why do
physicists even believe in beauty
i think um basically the reason is that
they don't think about what they're
doing as i said earlier these are
metaphysical
assumptions and this is just something
that uh physicists don't like to talk
about they don't even
write down that it's an assumption that
they are making
for the most part they actually leave it
a belief it's just
a mathematical criterion that they are
using
another part of the problem is that if
you try to pin them down on it
many of them will claim that it's
justified because the iraq and einstein
were successful
because they were guided by beauty and
maybe that's the story that you have
heard too
unfortunately it's um to begin with it's
wrong
um dirac and einstein certainly spoke
about beauty
but the reason that they ultimately were
successful as we know
know is um that they were
solving problems that actually required
a solution
they were both um facing inconsistencies
in the
theories at the time einstein was
facing the inconsistency between special
relativity and newtonian gravity
and dirac was looking at the
inconsistency between
special relativity and the then existing
formulation of quantum theory
and so they had a good problem to work
on it has it has
it had nothing to do with beauty really
and even if
it was right that it was beauty that led
them
to success that's cherry-picked data you
also have to look at the cases where
arguments from beauty did not work
and then and on that score you only have
to look at iraq and einstein themselves
because
after they had made their big successes
they tried to use arguments from beauty
um to develop some
fundamental great theory of everything
and it did not
work indeed
if you look at the history of physics
it's pretty clear that arguments from
beauty have just worked
badly so here's a brief selection of
beautiful ideas that just
didn't work there was this idea from
kepler
that the orbits of um the then known
five planets are determined by the way
that you can stack
certain types of polyhedra in inside
each other you see this in this
image from wikipedia but that just
turned out to be wrong
for various reasons um notably because
we now know that there are more than
five planets and also their orbits are
not circular
you know i i don't think it's a kind of
beauty that most people would even find
beautiful
um today um the circular orbits
themselves
were something that physicists were very
reluctant to give up on
because they thought well you know the
circle is the most beautiful
motion that you can think of so
certainly
if god had any choice making the last of
nature then he would have chosen the
circle
this is where this whole story with the
epicycles uh come from
where um people didn't want to give up
uh on
on these circles even when it didn't fit
on the data so they made circles around
circles around circles
again this is an idea of beauty that i
think no one would actually defend today
there was an episode in the history of
physics where
it became quite popular to believe that
um
atoms are really certain kinds of knots
uh in an invisible ether and i've
i have here an image of a certain kind
of plot as you can see it has a certain
aesthetic appeal i
i won't deny it and the theory also
turned out to be just wrong
um and for a long time just to add one
final example
it was considered to be beautiful that
the universe is in an external
in eternally unchanging state it just
has always been this way and will always
continue to be this way
uh today we also know that this is just
wrong
and then i already briefly mentioned
that both drock and einstein
uh in their late years tried to develop
their
um grand unified series of everything um
and
it worked badly and they were certainly
not the only one there were there were
many other people like
um iceberg uh ellington um and so on who
tried the same thing and it just
uh did not work and on the other hand we
have ugly ideas that
work just fine best example i could
think of is this fly trap
definitely ugly um but works quite well
quantum mechanics for example a lot of
my colleagues tend to find quantum
mechanics ugly um
i don't think myself that it is ugly um
but
you know in the end it's subjective to
who am i to disagree with them
whether or not you think that it's ugly
it works very well
in quantum field theory we have a
procedure called regularization
that we need to coax out
predictions from the mathematics a lot
of people think that this is ugly
um dirac for example was very opposed to
that whatever you think about it
it works just fine and then i already
mentioned that we have those elliptical
orbits
for the planets that were originally
considered to be very ugly
and the big bang theory of the universe
um there um so in in
in summary um you can say well there's
just no correlation between beauty and
explanatory power
um and there's also no reason to expect
this because
um evolution um did give us a sense of
beauty that is probably useful for some
things
for example um you know a lot of
biologists think that
our preference for certain symmetric
structures
um comes from the fact that um symmetry
is a good indicator for health
so there's probably an evolutionary
origin for that
however this has absolutely nothing to
do with the fundamental laws of nature
evolution did not prepare us to look for
laws that
dictate the behavior of things that we
can't see
there's another reason to be skeptical
about
arguments from beauty because standards
of beauty change
as a matter of fact it's not only that
they can change they do change
there's a very good book about this by
the philosopher uh james mcallister
beauty and revolution
in science he goes through some examples
where um
the standards of beauty have changed in
the scientific revolution
for example uh when going from the
geocentric to the heliocentric picture
of the solar system
or when switching from classical
mechanics uh to quantum mechanics
uh and so on so in in each of these
cases it was
a notion of beauty that was ultimately
been thrown out and replaced
uh by something new so um
the problem is that um it's really this
description of nature that makes
a theory beautiful so it's the end point
not the starting point so if you start
with making a particular assumption
about the type of beauty
then that's just not a very good
procedure and i think that's the reason
why
we are seeing this lack of progress in
the foundations
of physics it takes increasingly more
time and money to test
new theories and this means that
we must choose very very carefully which
theories to even put to test
and physicists just are not very careful
um so what has happened is in the past
40 years they have been sloppy in
choosing these theories
they were based on these arguments from
beauty which made them unpromising to
begin with then you go test them you get
negative experimental results so
negative experimental results are also
results of course but they're not very
useful results if you want to construct
a new theory so you get this lack of
data
and you get stuck with the unpromising
theories and
um this creates a vicious cycle that um
physicists have been in um for 40 years
basically
so um what's my progress proposal well
uh if you look at the history of physics
uh you will find
that um whenever there was a progress
led by theory of course there has been
progress led by experiment
but i'm i'm talking about progress by
theoretical predictions
this was led by resolving real
inconsistencies
in the theories so i suggest that before
physicists try to solve a problem they
make sure
it really is a problem and just because
the theory is not as beautiful as you
would like it to be
that doesn't mean the theory has a
problem it's really uh mathematical
problems that you need to be able to
um formally uh write down whose solution
has led to progress uh in the past
and so it makes sense just looking at
the evidence the historical evidence uh
to try and do that
again so what are those real problems uh
that we currently have on the
foundations of physics
well i already mentioned them in the
very beginning
we have this lack of a theory of quantum
gravity that's a case of an
actual inconsistency in the mathematics
we have the quantum measurement problem
that too is just a mathematical
inconsistency that
requires a solution we have dark matter
so this is not an internal inconsistency
in the theory but it's an actual
inconsistency with observation
so this two requires a solution
and there are certain aspects of dark
energy that are also inconsistencies
um but not all of them in particular
just the smallness of the cosmological
constant
is not in and by itself uh an
inconsistency
so this brings me to my summary uh using
criteria of beauty to assess theories
is bad scientific methodology it has not
worked
for 40 years to rely on arguments from
beauty
and continuing to insist that that's the
way to go
it's just not good science physicist
should stop doing this
there is no reason to think that it
should work it has not worked and it
does not currently work
and that's just not the way forward
finally allow me to say that i have
written a book in which i have
fleshed out these arguments some more
which will be published as a paperback
in about
10 days thank you for your attention for
more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you